here with more on all today's breaking
news developments I call them the great
one Mark Levin great one thank you for
being with us I know you got a lot to
say tonight
I have a prosecutor to use the wrong law
and I don't care how many former Federal
prosecutors and phony experts go on TV
because they have a law degree and they
think they know something when they know
nothing
most of them have spent their lives as
ambulance chases
now I know why the people hate lawyers I
don't blame them except for my wife and
me of course
here's the bottom line the
Espionage acts has no applicability to
this tell me how many people have been
prosecuted under the Espionage Act since
1917 who were president or vice
president up until today
zero
Lyndon Johnson took classified
information with him he had one of his
aides keep it they put it in an envelope
Johnson said not till I die give it to
my library
and then the library got it and they
were sitting on it for 50 years they
were told to involving top secret
information about Vietnam and tapping
the phone of Richard Nixon
um nobody remembers that isn't that
weird uh and of course you have the
Hillary Clinton example you know Hillary
Clinton was never investigated for
obstruction uh Sean it's not even that
they what they didn't investigate her
they didn't investigate her for perjury
and there was plenty of false statements
they'd even investigate her for that and
the evidence is beyond anything that
we've ever seen with a former Secretary
of State she wasn't even a former
president the presidential records act
doesn't even apply to her and so the
Espionage Act I would argue doesn't
apply to any former president or any
former vice president under the
presidential act why it's called the
presidential records ACT people come on
the TV and they say well he needs to
have the law applied to him as it would
anybody else no it's called the
presidential records act because he is
the executive branch he's the executive
branch so he doesn't have to rely on
some subordinate hear the regulations
this is the way you do it Mr President
his power comes from the Constitution
he is a third branch of government
him he alone everything else flows from
him the framers created a president they
didn't create a CIA they didn't create a
special counsel they didn't create an
attorney general they created a
president and this precedent that people
are talking about people need to pay
attention to this this was an Obama
judge trying to help Clinton in 2012 and
the Department of Justice should know
all about it and so should the National
Archives it was the case involving the
Sox the sock drawer and Judicial Watch
now what happened
Bill Clinton keeps these tapes which
have highly classified information on
them in his sock drawer
which is a little different than Sandy
Berger who kept him in his pants but
nonetheless he kept him in his sock
drawer then he retires he's a former
president so Judicial Watch brings a
lawsuit and says hey National Archives
go get those we want to see some of
those so it gets in front of this
Clinton judge Jackson in Washington and
what does she say
she reads the law the presidential
records act not the Espionage Act
or Clint would be doing 50 years with
his wife by now now he re she reads the
presidential records act and you know
what she concludes I'll tell you what
she concludes she says the responding
agency the National Archives the tapes
were Mr Clinton's personal records
therefore not subject
to the presidential records Act of the
Freedom of Information Act the
government's position was that Congress
had decided the president and the
president alone decides what his
presidential record and what isn't this
is why they want to keep talking about
the Espionage Act and not the
presidential records act we had a legal
analysts come on this network a few
hours back and he says
presidential records act doesn't apply
it's the federal records act because
these documents weren't created by the
Oval Office I said
how much Dumber is this going to get
before this is over
it's what's in the possession of the
president not whether he created it or
not not whether the vice president
created it not whether the the staff
created it president gets CIA
information the president gets Dia
information gets all kinds of
information it comes into the Oval
Office
some of which he might create most of
which he doesn't one other thing I have
a question
for Bill Barr in particular who's been
very poisonous
Bill Barr uh why wouldn't the
prosecutors seek a civil remedy if he
wants to seek any remedy at all
why wouldn't he go to the court and say
I need an order your honor order them to
turn all this stuff over under the
Espionage Act
well if the judge is smart the judge
will say get the hell out of my
courtroom what's this have to do with
the Espionage but maybe they're not so
smart maybe they're as dumb as the guy
that signed the warrant and so what
happens you need three elements you need
an order
and what are the elements for contempt
that yet judge can say okay I ordered
you to turn them over and you did okay
they go back the government said hold
them in contempt civil contempt a valid
order exists clearly defining an
obligation the accused party has the
ability to comply with the order the
accused party is willfully refused to
comply with the order then they're held
in civil contempt judge can decide if
one of the lawyers goes to Jefferson you
don't say you know what we're going to
move this as Barr did stupidly actually
we're going to move this from the
presidential records act to the
Espionage Act well how did they do that
they decided to criminalize the case
this entire prosecution
comes from the criminalization of the
case
the wrong statute the wrong statute so
you know what they're doing now Sean in
America they're beating up on the
potential judge ah she better be careful
oh she's a trump appointee so they know
what they're doing these people are
fascistic and Marxist that's what they
are they use the wrong law Donald Trump
did not commit any crimes he didn't
obstruct Justice he didn't commit
perjury he didn't make false statements
it is the prosecutor it is the attorney
general who did this and one other
question from Eric Garland what the hell
is it going to take you pal to appoint a
special counsel against Biden
allegations of bribery 17 potential
tapes and yet you know what Sean the
Attorney General knows all this
the FBI didn't turn this stuff over
without briefing the Attorney General
they have a very big table I think it's
on the fifth floor and he sits there and
they tell him what he's going to do same
with this prosecutor the Attorney
General is the Svengali behind it all
and the deputy attorney general is this
Bengali behind the Attorney General it's
the wrong law no president's ever been
charged for violating the Espionage Act
not Lyndon Johnson Hillary Clinton
wasn't charged she wasn't even
investigated for obstruction of justice
and one last thing I do have to give Joe
Biden some credit
1917 Woodrow Wilson was President he got
this law passed and he imprisoned 2 000
people
including Eugene Debs who was the
Socialist running for president and he
ran for president from prison and got
six percent of the vote
Wilson was a segregationist and a racist
Joe Biden was a segregationist and
racist so there you have it a former
segregationist and racist and a past
segregationist and racist using the
Espionage Act to try and destroy our
country and by the way illegal analysts
are coming on TV try to educate
yourselves try to look a little bit at
history obviously read the Constitution
read the case law be a little bit
informed before you go on TV and make an
ass out of yourself I'm done
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else